let's discuss how the president should
proceed with Larry Korb
of the Center for American Progress and
FoxNews foreign policy analyst Chiron
Skinner thank you both for being here we
really do appreciate it what are the
perils what are the problems what are
the challenges and you know what what
mine fields potentially lay out there
Larry well I think the real question is
what are your preconditions and what
will happen when you make a deal if you
do for example let's say Kim agrees to
give up all of his nuclear weapons the
question is how you going to verify that
it takes a couple of years to set up an
inspection regime as we saw in Iran and
even then the president doesn't think
it's it's it's that good and North Korea
is much more difficult to inspect what
will you do if you don't come to an
agreement then what next because Kim has
been legitimized I mean this is a
ruthless dictator who you know those
horrible things to his his own people
and now you have met with him something
he's been trying with the last four
presidents who turned turned him down so
he walks away with something I think
those that you should have thought of
that and even today they kept sending
different messages some preconditions no
preconditions you know what's your plan
normally when you have heads of state me
you have negotiators ahead of time work
out things but you do believe that the
president is doing the right thing and
that he should actually take this
meeting oh yeah I think he should but I
think he needs to do it in the right way
and under and lessen the risks now
chyron what's your take on this the
president is doing the right thing here
I think so and I disagree with Larry
core but the way he's presented it I
don't think the dangers and pitfalls
exist as much as many of the detractors
are trying to say for this particular
reason at least since 1992 we've had
discussions going on with and North
Koreans at lower levels in the US
government and they ended up in an
inconclusive way because we're dealing
with an authoritarian regime really a
totalitarian leadership it's important
that the top of the US government
be involved in the initial discussions
with the North Korean leader so what
looks unconventional I think really
reflects the reality of the failed
policy of more than a couple of decades
and we're going into this maybe there
are different messages coming out of
Washington and out of North Korea as a
result of this you know unusual
announcement and an unusual approach but
the fact remains that the US remains
committed to degrading North Korea it's
going in with the history behind its
back and having learned lessons of all
the failures of negotiations in the past
Larry how do you why do you think we
even got to this position I mean it
seems that the one thing that has
changed is President Trump he's actually
taken a very aggressive stance he's used
unconventional communication if you will
don't you give him some credence to that
or is it is there any belief that that
is actually what drove the North Koreans
to the table well I think there's two
things one he has reached a point where
he is ready to go nuclear since
president Trump's committees had 22
tests various things so he is where he
wants to be and the question becomes now
what next and if he's willing to give
this up even if you can verify the
question what is he gonna want in return
is he gonna ask us to take our troops
out of South Korea for example those are
questions that we need to think about
before we get in there and Chiron is
right I mean we've had negotiations that
haven't worked but even again you don't
want the president to go in and and make
a mistake because it's not like a
lower-level person making a mistake if
you know he does it you know then it's
very hard to undo Chiron doesn't matter
where this happens I mean the optics are
such a big part of this but you really
want to get to the substance of what's
happening where should they do this I
don't think it really matters but it
would be I think appropriate and
interesting to do it on the Korean
Peninsula I think it would send a major
signal to the Asian partners if it
happened there but let me just speak to
the point about the president I mean
making mistakes the president is not
going into negotiations with Kim jong-un
he's going into discussions and talks
if you go back to the Reagan
administration there was no possibility
of getting the first nuclear disarmament
agreement of the Cold War had it not
been for Reagan and Mikhail Gorbachev
building a personal relationship and
talking and Reagan talking with other
Russian leaders such as Anatoly Dobrynin
during those years so I think that we've
got to also give the president a kind of
wide latitude here because he's just
going to talk and begin to lay the
groundwork for the negotiations that
will follow
yeah but Reagan never did it without
George soles and cap Weinberger
Tillerson yesterday said he didn't think
we ought to have negotiation that same
day the president contradicted him
that's what I worry about what kind of
message always saying again listen unit
III I think this is a positive step
forward I thank you both for your
expertise on this topic we hope to have
you back and again thank you for joining
us tonight